foreign
worlds 2019 was a big deal from G2
proving that it is indeed possible for a
western team to compete with the best of
the best to fpx's incredible Cinderella
run to the championship will never ever
forget that tournament you might also
remember the outrageously cool spectacle
that was the 2019 World's opening
ceremony
[Applause]
but what have I told you that none of
that was the most important thing that
happened at Worlds that year that finals
weekend might have changed everything
for league but it wasn't because Riot
casually dropped another musical group
or because Dwayne B and Umi stole the
hearts of fans everywhere you see while
worlds was doing its thing Riot
technical teams were hard at work in
Paris testing something entirely new a
thrilling piece of technology that could
quite literally revolutionize the way
that they spread Esports to the world it
actually was our vendor it was like this
might be the first time this has ever
been attempted because it's so new
cutting edge bleeding edge but before
they could change everything Esports as
a whole came to a screeching halt
the talk about highs and lows we went
from this high where we had done
Holograms and we had had a successful
test of this new technology that we were
really excited about rolling out
globally to
be struggling to just keep Esports on
the air
um I'm kind of getting emotional because
it was it was it was such a jarring
change in our lives but in one of the
toughest times in the history of Esports
broadcasting this Plucky team of
Engineers Network technicians and
broadcasters brought their world back
from the brink and all their hard work
gave way to something even more
incredible
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
get started I just want to give a shout
out to Cisco and thank them for making
this video possible and sending me and
Liz and a whole bunch of other people
down to San Francisco to witness the
incredible finals in person they also
set up an extremely cool activation on
the ground that gave Folks At The Fan
Fest the chance to actually play 1v1s on
the same tournament server as the pros
at zero ping it was a really cool
experience and one that's gonna stick
with me for quite some time so thank you
again to Cisco for making all of this
possible alright so first things first
if you're gonna understand how Riot's
technical team made all of this happen
you're first gonna need to understand a
thing or two about League of Legends
broadcasting and how it works
I don't know it's super cool I promise
just
stick around you see when Ryan does a
broadcast for any event as big as World
they have to send signals over really
long distances we're talking from one
end of the world to the other and
sometimes uh at some events
that can get a little messy we saw
orange trees
now crying does have the destiny gate
foreign
and there are some things that are
things that have been done before that
you can look at and say right that's a
that's a solves problem it's something
that we can most likely figure out
without too much testing we can just go
with the leading vendor in that space
but there's other things like
transmitting video across the world
where it's like no we really need to do
that ourselves and figure it out and try
it out and dial ourselves in and really
understand before we choose to invest
effectively our players money into into
a big technology stack we want to make
sure that it works we made a whole video
back in the summer about how Riot
started solving this problem by turning
an Irish nightclub into a revolutionary
Production Studio so uh if you're
interested feel free to check it out
because what I just said will then make
a lot more sense that said I'm not
really the person who should be telling
you about all of this and thankfully I
don't have to be and now the guy who
actually actually knows what he's
talking about thanks for bringing me in
so early Dimitri something tells me
there's going to be some actual experts
in this video that I would rather not
compete with also hey Cisco good to see
you again if you need anybody to test
any of your 10 gig switches my mailbox
is always open
okay listen as somebody who's done his
fair share of remote broadcasting in the
last couple of years let me tell you
it's not easy from my own basement
Studio to even Productions in our
offices there's a lot that can go wrong
so when it comes to the scale of events
like worlds Riot has some pretty insane
levels of complexity to manage a lot of
different technology has been used to
keep things running over the years but
in 2019 Riot was testing out a fancy new
video coding format called jpeg XS what
is a video coding format well without
getting too deep into the weeds you can
think of it as a set of rules and
instructions for how to compress
transmit store and decompress the data
in a video stream but there are a lot of
different video coding formats out there
so what's so special about this one
thankfully I read the white paper so you
don't have to jpeg access has some truly
impressive stats in three of the most
important areas for live video streaming
normally when streaming video you're
forced to choose between your desired
latency quality and the complexity of
the physical Hardware you want to use
want a low latency and high quality
video feed well traditionally you'd need
to dish for some exceptionally expense
it's a video Hardware but with jpeg
access things are a little different
with jpeg access latency for one
encoding decoding cycle is below a
couple of lines that's lines as in
literal lines of pixels being drawn for
the video so about as real time as it
gets in terms of quality jpeg access
does compress the video to ensure it can
be transmitted quickly over your
standard 1 to 10 gigabit networks now I
haven't seen any visual comparisons to
uncompressed video but everything I've
read calls it indistinguishable so they
feel pretty safe saying that it can at
least hold its own even with 4K
streaming on the horizon but even better
to get all of that you don't need NASA
level Hardware jpeg XS was designed with
a focus on low power and low resource
implementations even on consumer grade
Hardware so jpeg access is cool but you
guys have heard enough for me and I
would just rather get on with the video
and hear from some actual experts who
have actually used it and that was the
guy who actually knows what he's talking
about so anyways jpeg XS was new it was
exciting is that really what it's called
jpeg Xs
sounds like the name of an up-and-coming
meme rapper anyway over in Paris Riot's
Global head of Esports technology the
homie Scott adamets who you'll remember
from videos past was part of the team
that finally realized the jpeg thing
worked we were so early days of this
technology that it was literally had
never actually been attempted across the
Atlantic and we didn't kind of boast
about that some press found out and
we're like you know this is probably the
first time actually it was a vendor was
like this might be the first time this
has ever been attempted because it's so
new cutting edge bleeding edge so like
we've said broadcasting when players and
talent are on other sides of the planet
can be an absolute nightmare but jpeg XS
could make it all easier and change the
way that all these broadcasts actually
work and then
coveted it look we've made a lot of
videos about the effects that the
pandemic has had and is still having on
Esports but for this small Tech Team
over at Riot who are trying to solve
these really sophisticated issues kovid
was a brick wall it didn't matter if
Riot was on the brink of revolutionizing
Esports broadcasting for Live Events
there weren't any Live Events to
revolutionize and I remember it working
uh and us being like well okay we have
we have a transmission method for
striker
and not a few months later the pandemic
hit and we lost access to all of our
production facilities all of our
regional Studios and we had to spend the
next year kind of rebuilding and trying
to get through the pandemic and keep
these Sports on the air and it wasn't
just the tech team the broader world of
League of Legends moved online and
though relatively few events had to be
canceled any longtime fan will tell you
there's no debate something very
important was missing
the talk about highs and lows we went
from this high where we had done
Holograms and we had had a successful
test of this new technology that we were
really excited about rolling out
globally to
struggling to just keep Esports on the
air I'm kind of getting emotional
because it was it was it was such a
jarring change in our lives like it's
like shared PTSD for the whole world and
all we're trying to do is bring joy to
fans you brought up this idea of like
what was it like during the pandemic
doing shows like we kept doing shows we
really didn't have to cancel much but we
couldn't invite audiences to celebrate
and I can tell you being in an empty
quiet Arena because we already had the
Arenas booked so we we went and it was
just silence it's it's not something I
ever want to go back to at the end of
2020 Dan Juan made history by bringing
the world's crown back to Korea on the
back of one of the most dominant
tournament runs we've ever seen and
while there was a small crowd huge
swaths of the stadium had to be
completely empty it was a hugely
important win but compared to the highs
of Paris it felt sort of hollow now even
despite the setbacks the tech team did
their best to keep their projects moving
forward and although their plans for
jpeg XS were supposed to be deployed in
2020 by the time MSI was coming back for
2021 they were finally ready and when
the tech team brought examples of the
new tools to the crew in Iceland at MSI
they were shocked to find that it was
faster than their existing Tech if we're
conducting an interview across
continents usually we'll have a path
that's really fast for audio to get
through so we can converse normally and
then the video team will actually fix
the alignment of the video streams in a
very live kind of post-production way
and so it will look like a natural
conversation on on video when you're
watching as a viewer but the presenters
won't necessarily see each other
naturally they'll hear each other
naturally but what we found with this
new technology was that both could
happen and instead of having to put all
of these mitigations in place we could
just throw the live transmission from La
onto a monitor in front of the host in
LEC and they could just talk to it and
they could have a natural conversation
and it was so good that Riot didn't even
wait to implement it and we tested it we
were able to it's no joke we had no
plans to use it in production we did not
say they should
but it got used in production uh we
looked up one one moment and we were
seeing our feed on that super early Tech
was taken for the opening of the show
and to the it worked so Riot knew that
they were working with something real
they knew that there could be actual
potential and behind the scenes Scott
was on his way to convincing his bosses
that it was time to invest big in this
Tech meanwhile things in the scene were
starting to change after years with
limited audiences in 2022 the League of
Legends scene started coming back to
life everything came together at Worlds
the biggest event of the year was back
in North America for the first time
since 2016 and boasting full crowds for
the first time since Paris it's Unique
being in a venue and hearing the crowds
cheer and do the countdown and the fist
it's like nothing else not only do I
remember uh when was my first time
coming back and having fans in an
audience it was today it was literally
when we opened up the fan Village and we
let everyone in to actually enjoy Fan
Fest and I saw smiling people I saw
people getting excited about Swag and
t-shirt cannons and and cheering I got
to meet some of the fans playing at zero
pink for the first time I can't tell you
how much I missed that but that is not
to say that putting together an event as
huge as worlds is ever easy I think I
probably speak for a lot of the
engineering team that work on the back
end systems there is a lot of almost
self-inflicted if you would use that
word pressure where we hold ourselves to
a very high standard and no one is more
acutely aware the the gravitas of
failure or the systems that we work on
and we carry uh that in in kind of
everything we do because we know that
those moments you see you don't want to
see a team fight impacted by anything
other than the rules and the content of
League of Legends so when we plan these
events obviously we start about a year
in advance um but it's not just the
venue like a lot of people think the the
olive worlds is just the venue no no
like group stage we've got you know up
to 16 teams
um they're they have to have practice
rooms because the sport requires them to
practice with their team so not many
people know but we set up Hotel practice
rooms we pull out all the furniture we
set up gaming tables uh chairs and seven
PCS those PCS need to be connected to a
network and the network is run through
literally if you were at a hotel and you
like took the TV off the wall there's
some Network ports on the wall we use
those and we patch it all back down and
then another room somewhere in the in
the hotel we don't tell you which one is
the server room that's where we put an
offline game server and that offline
game server which is crucial to making
worlds happen is something we've already
made a video about the realm the realm
is an offline server powered by Cisco
which allows riots to deploy a zero ping
environment and it's used for pretty
much every major tournament Riot puts on
and it's like very secret our camera
operator Matt the cat Massey was
literally one of the first people to
ever be allowed to film the room where
they keep the realm at Worlds but we're
not allowed to show that to you sorry
even Faker is not allowed in there is
Faker allowed in there like can you just
roll in and take a selfie with his
finger hush thing beside the server rack
you should ask Cisco I wanna know on the
plus side there are versions of the
realm that Riot can share with the world
including one our friends over at Cisco
set up to give fans outside the stadium
in San Francisco the chance to
experience true zero pain look at this
they just left it out in a crowd of
hundreds of people although I guess it
is like right there in the open like
even gumayushi would have trouble
stealing that anyway the point is that
even just making the games at Worlds
possible in the first place is a massive
lift and as the tournament progressed
through North America one more piece of
History came together though the North
American facility in Seattle is still
under construction the striker Studio in
Dublin was able to contribute to a
broadcast that featured 20 seven streams
in 23 languages thanks to all of this
Tech from Cisco and Riot people all over
the world were able to watch the
tournament pretty much seamlessly
especially compared to some of the
challenges broadcasters faced during
covet and wow what a tournament it was
[Applause]
always
division 4K Health should be a clean
spite
[Applause]
by the time finals rolled around I think
we all knew that this world was
something special from emotional moments
to incredible outplays to story lines
that should really earn Riot's script
writers arrays this was an event that I
personally will never forget this was
also the first Finals with a full crowd
since everything changed in 2020. so
when I got to sit in the audience for
the countdown it was also Scott and
James's first time being in a packed
arena in years the culmination of all
that work all that effort I actually
find myself looking at the crowd more
than I find myself looking at the stage
I'll go out there and use my credit
essential and I'll just look at everyone
cheering in this entire Arena section
and they're they've brought like
thundersticks and they have signs and
they're yelling and shouting and hugging
that that's the cool part to me for me
worlds it's this moment in time yeah
I've been at Riot for a while but every
time when Worlds runs around it doesn't
matter if I'm there or if I'm not
there's just this moment where I kind of
I see what's going on and you get this
moment of Pride for me it's just a
moment of like pride and joy that we've
done it again the fans are enjoying this
amazing event and seeing this the
reactions that we get it's kind of a
validation of everything that we do we
got to enjoy another really special
opening ceremony complete with even more
Hollow Net Technology than they employed
back in Paris we got to watch Lil Nas X
put on a live show and seriously he was
amazing but we also got to watch what
worlds is supposed to be it's more than
a tournament more than the highlights
and more than the trophy worlds is
community it's a moment for Esports fans
from pretty much everywhere to come
together and celebrate the game that
they love in one stadium in one place
Under One Roof and we really missed that
you know what it is we can talk about
this Matt we can talk about this so I
went like one in seven for the first
eight 1v1s I was I was trying to play
MooMoo and then I won the next seven in
a row after I switched to other
Champions but Matt over here left it all
out he literally just cut that whole
second half out he's like oh Dimitri got
bullied in the 1v1s LOL you got roasted
buddy and the interview he literally did
the interview in the hotel room he
wouldn't even let me talk about how the
fact that I made an insane turnaround